everybody likes to make fun of cornell
nyu is so beneath you
this is more accurate hi i'm morgan and
i'm kennedy and we went to dartmouth
college hi i'm katie and i'm a senior at
brown university hi my name is elish i
went to columbia hey i'm sienna and i'm
a rising senior at harvard college
[Music]
oh my gosh of course of course okay oh
this is oh i just saw this movie for the
first time i'm going to tell all of you
at harvard why i'm going to make an
amazing hell yeah she is
i feel like this is accurate this is
what the admissions department looks
like 4.0 from c-u-l-a and she got a 179
on her lsats did she say she got a 179
or elsa that's like unheard of this is
true you have some people who are like
rooting for you and others that aren't
welcome to harvard oh gosh i hope the
admissions committee looks a lot more
diverse than that i mean that is kind of
this harvard stereotype it's like a
bunch of old white guys in the
admissions department i'd say like the
holistic review of the admissions i
think that's something that's very
prided upon by like any ivy league and
mission sport at least at harvard we
have the right to
see our application
after we've been admitted and see our
interviewers comments on us and also the
admissions officer's comment
columbia columbia
that's her first mistake she's wearing
high heels in new york as if you can
walk more than two blocks in this i'd
come and watch your lacrosse game so if
you can make one thing this gets wrong
is the idea that anyone would go watch a
lacrosse game but yeah we were
notoriously bad at sports but for some
reason we were the best at medieval
sports like archery fencing or anything
that looked like it involved a torture
device we're celebrating we just got the
most amazing apartment ever we would
totally approve
pre-war doorman who can't afford a
doorman in college i know who can what
do you think about falafel ew
isn't that the kind of food paralegalsy
i never thought
the upper west justice for paralegals
oh my god are you transferring to
colombia i hope so nyu is so beneath you
oh the elitism ah that's so mean
we have definitely encountered people
who like look down at non-ivy league
schools you know i think there's always
going to be people who feel like they're
better than other people for all kinds
of reasons i really included when i
first went to brown i did have a culture
shock of like the crazy elite
populations that do run in those circles
there were a few people here and there
that dressed like this and threw money
around and a lot of those kids were part
of a house called saint a's allegedly
one of the things you had to do to get
in is buy a plane ticket to china and
then burn it and this clip is shot on
the same block as that house
oh my god the van wickle gates
that's way better than what it looks
like in real life
i got this at the school store
harvard does sell like art prints at the
museum yeah they violated a lot of dorm
guidelines by hanging like a literal
glass framed thing on the wall that you
will get fined stewie i can't use this
it'll be cheating oh fine listen i'll be
out on the quad yeah people hanging on
the water the green was something that
everyone did and i was never feeding to
play spike ball or a toss down a frisbee
huge ultimate frisbee scene at brown
no brown is often dubbed as the chillest
ivy honestly i take that title in stride
i'm very grateful to brown's culture for
chilling me the freak out i would say
the work environment at harvard is very
like work hard play hard maybe more
emphasis on the work hard in my
experience cheating is still taken very
very seriously you would get suspended
for like up to
three terms at dartmouth if you
plagiarized
oh my gosh the social network of course
those girls are all going to a final
club they're probably from like bu or
another boston school
[Music]
like i feel like in movies everyone that
goes to harvard it's like either this
bookish brainiac who's like him coding
away on saturday night or with his
friends in the back smoking facebook
there's no in between
this is so accurate like the guys at the
door
ushering some of the girls in
all the guys in suits so accurate
such bougie parties have never been
invited to one of those everyone in this
movie is a lot hotter than their real
life equivalents
i need you i'm here for you
no i need the algorithm you use during
chess players are people in some
algorithm they always want some
algorithm from you so final clubs at
harvard are really a different breed
they're one of the most controversial
things i think about harvard there is a
huge history of these being very elitist
very privileged very white this does
kind of point to an interesting thing
about these schools they have this aura
of being exclusive and then even within
them there are levels of exclusivity so
you might see people like mark who feel
left out even though they're the most
you know prestigious school ever
i seem to lack the basic understanding
that my peers just intuitively grasped
[Music]
her
name who wears heels on campus that's
badass go girl how many people in
college do you know that you met
randomly like that saw each other on the
quad college you're cute i got your
number i know zero
oh are they gonna be making out in the
library sex yep
too soon bro
one of the biggest misconceptions people
have about the ivy league is
that everyone's super smart there are a
surprising number of really dumb people
at these schools someone might be
really adept at
one or two things but then totally inept
at everything else namely social cues
emotional intelligence i know it seems
like kind of contrived but i know at
least like three people who have been
rejected in the rain at columbia there
definitely is i think some accuracy to
like the adorable stereotype or whatever
the girl is very dressed up though which
i love um but not a lot of people at
harvard would dress up but i think also
back in the day a lot of black people
were told by their parents to dress up
for stuff like school the airport maybe
it was like a cultural thing it's so
weird to see so many black people
represented in ivy league school because
i feel like when you think about ivy
league schools i think like white people
yeah like some really black people there
skull and bones is a secret society that
some of the students are allowed into oh
this is intense
very swanky
but i guess they have the budget for it
because it's yellow
i'm not going to say nothing i'm not
going to say anything i'm not going to
say nothing
this is very cool
are they gonna like burn each other or
something i i i i'm getting bad vibes
they're gonna brand them definitely on
the ass cheek now
i knew it
do you know how long you should hold
something about on your skin to actually
make a brand like if it's a secret then
why would you brand your wrist
right after
oh i felt that besties for life i've
heard that the presidents that have
graduated from yale like a lot of them
have been part of these secret societies
they are still operating but like their
recruitment processes are very very
low-key i've heard that but like
obviously i've never
been recruited so harvard doesn't really
have as far as i know secret societies
like they have the final clubs and those
are really out there like i feel like
every society is really just like a
social club where you can hang out and
drink kiss a bear too at dartmouth when
you graduate everyone from their
different society like gets a cane so
then you can flex and be like i was in
this society it's the final social flex
okay animal house darth vader membership
jim larry kroger
very dartmouth
as i would think that dartmouth is like
a more legitimate school than the school
portrayed in this movie so they're
rushing
why are men of dartmouth portrayed as
being ugly is it true
it's funny because dartmouth is
portrayed like especially in animal
houses very
legacy familial things like that but
everywhere else talks about it as rough
around the edges and kind of raunchy
see this is more accurate
excuse me
come on in i love how they're in suits
the vibes are already better here
i feel like it looks like how gdx
society looks like really
the random keep out signs
those were everywhere
this is very accurate this feels a lot
more accurate
so animal house is based on a frat at
dartmouth allegedly allegedly called a.d
it's like no longer a fraternity
freshman year of college i was dating a
guy who was in a.d before it got shut
down and um he really talked about it as
being like the most fun house on campus
like it was the it was the craziest they
did brand people i could see a few
brands i used to hear they had a budget
for drugs yeah not the california kind
the other kind i wouldn't say that clip
is super accurate for harvard it's more
like stand around and talk i like this
one i think they hit a lot of things on
the head
corner
everybody likes to make fun of cornell
and the ivy leagues i love cornell i
feel so bad for cornell students who are
fans of the office i feel like they
really ragged on them with this guy
people who went to ivy's are like this
though
they're all just mad like protective
over there like almond water kind of
living in their college days a little
bit still you know who you are and it
does also take me back to when i was
doing interviews a very very
nerve-wracking process like honestly the
interviewers are kind of arbitrary i do
know that a lot of them will give
comments though sometimes
people have gone back and read what
their interviewers said and some of them
would make comments on their appearance
but the only interview i remember is my
cornell interviewer and it was a very
pleasant experience so very very
inaccurate representation they are going
to go to the vastly superior dartmouth
it's true it's true that's an unpopular
opinion i feel like school rivalry is
really real no one is ashamed of going
to colombia but i don't think we have
the sort of pride that someone who went
to ole miss has oh there's like no
school pride
i think there is inherent like deep
individual private i'd say as a
collective it is a little harder to
rally the troops i would say school
pride at harvard is like really low i
mean when people ask you where you go to
school harvard people will not say
harvard i feel like at dartmouth people
are
less ostentatious about where they went
because sometimes people don't even know
what dartmouth is but amongst each other
it's like a cult i think the main thing
is that if you have a large group of
people they are going to resemble any
other large group of people a lot of
these clips were very like male oriented
white oriented and in the ivy league
institutions they are trying to
break that trope so i do think we're
making a lot of progress but there's
definitely also still a lot of work to
be done
[Music]
you